używanie służb specjalnych do inwigilowania kumpli
opozycji prokuratorów czy dziennikarzy
czy niezależnych adwokatów jest czymś
w demokratycznym państwie
służby muszą działać
służby mają swoją robotę
ale muszą być pod kontrolą demokratycznej
pod kontrolą sądowa i to jest kwestia 1/2 kwestia
to jest obraz prawa i sprawiedliwości
który kreuje się w ostatnich dniach
znaczy to jest partia zdegenerowana
która podsłuchuje swoich kumpli
najbardziej podejrzanymi są ludzie waszych szeregów
podgryzacie sobie aorty
kopiecie się Po kostkach
nie wierzycie sobie
zaglądacie sobie za firanki
podsłuchujecie siebie nawzajem
inwigilujecie
jakby to jest obraz partii upadłej
to znaczy nie ściganie przestępców
nie ściganie tych
którzy powinni być inwigilowani zgodnie z prawem
tylko
człowieka z wewnątrz partii
nawet Kaczyński podsłuchiwał
no to przecież to jest jakiś odlot
wy jesteście partią
sobie nie wierzy
nie ufa nienawidzicie się nawzajem
a używaliście służb specjalnych niezgodnie z przepisami
dostaje sędzia 80
100 wniosków dziennie o
legalizację kontroli operacyjnej
czasami nawet imienia
nazwiska nie ma tej osoby
która będzie inwigiliowana
no przecież jakieś zaufanie w państwie pomiędzy
służbami i sądami powinno być
chociaż wy zniszczyliście to zaufanie pomiędzy służbami
a sądami bo przecież sąd musi mieć pewność
że Jak dostaje na biurko wniosek
to znaczy że nikt nie wprowadza sądu w błąd
chociaż panie mistrzu
my właśnie wprowadzaliśmy w błąd